[Music]
[Applause]
bringing the popular peter king football
morning and america economist
if the nfl asked you a week ago pete
what would you suggest for overtime in
the postseason what would you say
i'd say
you should do exactly what they did
dan
i think
all the other things that are discussed
are interesting
just continuing playing football having
a timed quarter all that stuff
it's all interesting
but i think the one issue
that
solves almost everything
is simply mandating that the other team
get a position the second team get a
possession and i'll tell you why
the nfl
one of the reasons that they didn't pass
this in the regular season
is that coaches don't want to create
longer football games in general
and the players union is adamantly
against creating longer games especially
now that the league has gone to a
17-game season
and i understand all the other things
that have been discussed and i think all
of them have merit i mean everyone you
know the merit of just continuing to
play football
but i do think that this one
basically solves all the global issues
and then i think one of the other things
that it does
it's going to add
uh in my opinion intended consequences
of having a much more strategic decision
and decisions to be made in overtime
because i believe that most coaches now
if they win the toss to start overtime
are going to defer yep you want the ball
second because you want to know what you
have to do if you hold the team on first
down and all you need is a field goal to
win that's different obviously so
i think it's going to it's going to it's
going to create some strategy that
doesn't currently exist yeah i was just
going to ask you if you were a coach and
you won the coin toss
you're more likely to probably defer
i'm guessing the numbers the analytics
may bear that out
i'm sure you know
there can be none yet because
this hasn't existed but i i don't know
why you wouldn't take the ball second
um
you know unless you're a huge believer
in momentum and if you have finished
uh the fourth quarter by scoring 10
points in two minutes and the crowd's
going crazy and then you you get your
choice
or
you know whatever you you would probably
then choose
you might choose to take the ball but i
think most coaches are going to defer
yeah that's a great point of momentum
and riding that momentum
um
the
situation going on with desean watson
and the commissioner and he said he's
not going to put him on the
commissioner's exempt list
which is a big story by the way yeah i
was surprised at that why why do you
think he said he wouldn't put him on the
exempt list
i think it's pretty simple
uh that
i think the nfl is a little bit i don't
want to say fearful but they have
trepidation about using that as a
catch-all because they've used it in the
past and
you know
i i also think dan that
can you imagine
if you were the haslems
and you're already under fire and and
just imagine if they put this guy on the
commissioner's exempt list until all of
his legal issues had been adjudicated
and you had to pay 46 million dollars to
a player for not playing in a season if
all these issues weren't adjudicated
but i do think it's significant they
said that and now i think the big
question is
if they do wait for all of those uh
suits to be settled
one way or the other
and theoretically it's possible that he
wouldn't be suspended till 2023
theoretically
and we looked at the restructuring of
that contract or the structuring of that
contract and he's going to make a little
over a million and as i pointed out
yesterday while it looks like
he's kind of bracing himself to be
suspended
aaron rodgers is only going to make him
yeah most contracts are done that way
the only reason why everybody brought
that up and why i said that made me so
angry i wanted to spit nails
is because it's very clear
that the browns like this that that was
a selling point
clearly to desean watson to say that hey
listen we are totally in your corner and
no matter what happens this year
we're going to hand you 45 million
signing bonus and we're not going to ask
for any of it back regardless how long
you're suspended for
we're talking to peter king football
morning in america columnist
who do you think is in
more in limbo garoppolo or baker
mayfield
probably garoppolo because i would
expect that something would happen with
baker mayfield before the draft i'm not
sure that garoppolo
will get traded before the draft i think
that kyle shanahan and john lynch
absolutely have
told him they love jimmy garoppolo love
them
and they're going to do the best thing
for garoppolo if at all possible but i
can see a scenario if i were the 49ers
right now i'd hang on to jimmy garoppolo
until something
uh
non-fortuitous
fortuitous for the 49ers but bad for
somebody else some quarterback gets hurt
and there's a desperate need for one and
i could see that happening and if i were
them that's exactly what i do i'm not
trading them for a four
or something like that i'm hanging on to
them because look the 49ers are in
position
in a weakened nfc
to get to the super bowl they came very
close last year to getting to the super
bowl and so why would they give up the
insurance
of being really good at the quarterback
positions so i think they hang on to him
until they get a decent offer what's
like when teddy bridgewater got injured
and sam bradford was traded from the
eagles and they i think got a number one
pick uh our first round pick for him and
that trade happened dan that trade
happened on sunday of labor day weekend
or saturday on labor day weekend like
eight days before the season started so
that's why you hang on to jimmy
garoppolo because
you just never know what's going to
happen
and then baker mayfield with that salary
that that would be a nice salary for a
starting quarterback but nobody wants to
pay 18 million dollars for a guy that
you're not sure if he'll be a starting
quarterback is that the biggest hang up
here yeah i mean well that plus the fact
that most teams have settled their
quarterback
uh situation uh and and that hasn't
included baker mayfield the thing is dan
do you want to pay 18.9 million dollars
uh
for a quarterback to play 17 games
who
you're not sure he's going to be
anything other than a bridge quarterback
for your team
imagine you're the carolina panthers and
you would sign them let's just say
i mean first of all then
you stand in the way of getting some
final answer on sam darnold
you might stand in the way of saying man
we love malik willis
uh let's just take him at number six
and and if you're seattle
i mean you if you were to sign baker
mayfield in seattle you would want i
would think
to do an extension with them and say hey
look we're going to give you a real
chance to be our quarterback
but we don't want to hamstring ourselves
financially to do it
yeah it feels like if i'm
carolina you know a couple of these
teams you mentioned
i may just try to get through this year
i may roll the dice may draft somebody
and just and see if i find you know gold
here not bring somebody in who's going
to be ready to get extended and want you
know whatever kind of money if he has a
successful year
you know this is a funny year for the
draft and because
you saw in december everybody said
no quarterback's going to get picked
till 26 or you know you were seeing all
those things well now
you have all the pro days and you got
one team that's excited about desmond
ritter you've got a couple of teams that
are really excited
uh
you know about about malik willis
uh you know and obviously kenny pickett
the interesting story about kenny
pickett
is that if you really search deep into
the archives the deep internet
and you guys can find this it's
hilarious
there is a photo
of matt rule
and high school junior
kenny pickett
posing at temple university
after he agreed uh you know committed to
go to temple and then
seven months or eight months later matt
rule was gone he rescinded his
commitment changed a pit but that has
drawn a lot of people to say hey what
about the panthers and kenny pickett and
just imagine though what would be really
interesting if pickett makes it to the
top of the second round
who knows carolina could end up picking
him okay we have a draft bet paulie
thinks that a quarterback will be
selected in the first 13 picks
uh i would i would agree with that
but
i would also say
that i'm not at all convinced that
whoever picks
a quarterback will pick at their
original their current spot
i would not be surprised let's say the
steelers are in love with malik willis i
don't know that they are they aren't
but uh
mike tomlin and kevin colbert have been
to all these pro days
but whoever the steelers pick 20th if
there's a guy they really want
you know they've shown it they'll be
active to try to move for him
great to talk to you pete hope you're
doing well and uh thanks for joining us
as always okay dan all the best to you
that's peter king football morning and
america columnist and contributor to
football night america